presented by youtube tv mark jackson  nice to see you honest with you  kupo back on the floor spectacular play  in transition  pursuing and denying what a play  well you know how many guys give up on  plays giannis  off a knee injury no one would expect  him to make that play  we've seen it before mike although this  was game seven  and perhaps the championships all starts  with the switching of lopez  it puts too much pressure on your  defense paul deflects it  crowded and bridges bridges up inside  blocked by attenua  what a recovery when the bucks come the  other way  holiday spins layup shot will go and  lopez is fouled  for a guy with a hyper-extended knee  what a fantastic defensive play  this is reminiscent of lebron james  in cleveland against golden state what  an effort  [Applause]  incredible block  [Applause]  he only knows one way to play just  perfect timing